what about say with the concept of white
privilege hello and welcome to
trigonometry I'm Francis Foster I'm
constant in kissin and this is a show if
you're bored with people arguing on the
internet over subjects they know nothing
about a trigonometry you don't pretend
to be the experts we ask the experts are
brilliant guests this week is a
professional rapper creative
entrepreneur and podcaster zubi welcome
to trigonometry does that pay guys don't
[Music]
know man it's good to have you here
listen before anyone who doesn't know
who you are tell us quickly what's your
story how are you where you are what's
been the journey that has you sitting in
this chair okay let's do it
so I am zubi I'm an independent
professional full time rapper and
creative entrepreneur I Wow
I'm from a lot of places I was born in
the UK I grew up in the Middle East in
Saudi Arabia lived there for well over a
decade went to school there for a while
went to a international school hence the
hybrid American British accent I then
went on I went to a boarding school in
the UK I went to Oxford University
studied computer science there graduated
worked in London corporate job for a
couple of years whilst juggling my music
career on the side I started making
music when I was in university and in
2011 I went to pursue my music full-time
left my full-time job and I've now been
doing music and a couple other creative
bits including my new podcast real talk
with zubi of yeah now been doing it
full-time for over seven years so here
we are it's good to have them and
there's so many things we want to talk
to you about because you've been in the
news and there's well maybe let's start
by talking about rap because one of the
things I really like about your music is
you have a very positive message you
don't talk about you know gangs and all
that kind of stuff is that a conscious
decision in your path yeah somewhat I
mean my music reflects me I'm a very
educated guy from a relatively
privileged background which is you know
not the
typical hip-hop rapper story so I don't
ever try to represent myself as anything
that I'm not there's a lot of negativity
out there in the world not just in music
and entertainment but just in a lot of
the messaging and in the way a lot of
people are and the way people behave so
with me I just always try to be
authentic I don't try to add to the
negativity I want to put a message out
there that is positive it's inspiring
motivates people when people hear my
music when they're listening to my
tracks the best feedback I can get is
and that motivated me that inspired me I
hate the way it's harder in the gym it
made me go and pursue that job or pursue
that dream so that's what I'm trying to
do for people I want to be a positive
light I also want to keep it completely
real you know I like to be very honest
and authentic in both my music and the
way I just am and the way I treat people
in general but I want to do it in a way
that's positive and so you're talking
about positivity and rap because a lot
of hip-hop music you know especially
gangsta rap it's about negativity it's
about violence it's about gang culture
how much responsibility do these artists
have to their listeners or do they not
have any at all and they're just simply
telling their truth well I think that
everybody I think this goes beyond music
I think that everybody has a
responsibility in how they conduct
themselves and the message that they put
out there to the world I think once you
once you're a grown adult I mean even as
a child but certainly as an adult
whether or not you want to be a role
model especially if somebody is a public
figure you're gonna be a role model kind
of by default it doesn't necessarily
mean that that's who children should be
looking up to like a child should
certainly shouldn't be having a rapper
as their prime role model in life nor
should it be an actor or sports person
right in a perfect world it should be it
should be their parents family members
older brother who whoever it is you know
family teachers you know people around
them that's really what it's for so I
certainly don't so there's always that
sort of argument about how much
responsibility should be on rappers or
musicians versus other stuff because on
one hand I do think that there is a
responsibility just as a like I said as
an adult but at the same time
you don't it's also not that argument
where something bad will happen or
people behave in a negative way and
people try to blame it on music or video
games or movies it's a much more nuanced
conversation like then that like a lot
of things people try to make everything
black and white and very binary but um I
think you know coming back to that first
question you asked me you said my music
is very positive and it inspires people
and I know for a fact it inspires people
because I've talked spoken to people
it's inspire so it wouldn't make any
sense to say that music can have a
positive influence but it's impossible
for it to have a negative influence you
see what I mean yeah so there obviously
is it's kind of like a chicken and egg
thing you know a lot of rappers who rap
about gangster self will say I'm just
rapping about my life or I'm documenting
what's happening in the streets or
whatever which can be true but there's a
line between documentation and
glorification and I'd be lying if I said
that there are not certainly artists
some artists who are trying to make it
sound really cool to go out and kill
people or sound cool to take drugs or
sell drugs or whatever the case may be
so in my personal opinion that's when it
kind of crosses that boundary but um
perhaps a better question might be why
does why does it appeal to people you
know what is it that makes that music
sell because people are only going to
supply what people demand so maybe a
better question is you know why are we
drawn to violent lyrics violent
videogames violent films you know why
are we drawn to all these things I think
that perhaps might be a better question
which nobody ever seems to ask
I love these just everywhere isn't it I
don't tell me what you think I'm guess
part of that is that we are drawn to
things that we've done ourselves
necessarily experienced in our own life
so we're kind of living through someone
else you know like when we watch a movie
about someone taking revenge with a gun
like I would never go out and do that
but I have thought of you know yes the
racism has begun guys I've seen you with
your nacho
oh yeah I think that's a factor I think
the I think the true reason is a bit
deeper and darker I think human beings
particularly guys we're all we're all
men here we're all males you know there
is something in our brain yeah I know
I'm sorry I'm such a bigot I I think
there's something innately in us from a
kind of evolutionary perspective that is
wired for sex and violence and the
reason for that is obvious because in
terms of survival we've always needed
these two things and it's relatively
it's very recent that we're actually
living in a relatively peaceful stable
society like all for the look at last
several hundreds thousands of years men
have always been going to war we've been
going to war we've been have been
pillaging and you know reproducing and
just that's kind of been the way forward
so it's like now we live in a very
fortunately a very safe stable civilized
society but I still think you know
you've still got that thing in your your
lizard brain it's got like a very primal
thing that is drawn to violence or sex
or whatever it might be and you'd
obviously don't want to manifest that in
a negative way but you some people do
that and we call them criminals right
there are people who go out there and do
horrible things but I think that you
know if you're playing a violent video
game and you're shooting people up in
the game or you're playing GTA and
chucking people out of cars and do it
doing all this stuff that you wouldn't
dream of doing in the real life I think
it's kind of satisfying that that innate
craving yeah without actually doing
anything that's gonna have a negative
impact on you or on society so that
that's my kind of theory I think the
same goes with listening to really
aggressive music I think the same goes
with our watching action films where
stuff is just blowing up and people are
doing all kinds of stuff to each other I
think it's all kind of the same it's
essentially cathartic yeah yeah exactly
that's what I think and so be where do
you stand on the whole free speech thing
when it comes to rap music do you think
it's ever acceptable because there were
two grime artist recently who were
arrested and all the rest of it for
lyrics do you think it's ever acceptable
to arrest people for their lyrics and/or
to ban people from platforms like
YouTube or do you think ultimately it is
free speech and everybody's entitled to
it
well I'm essentially if I'm pretty close
to a free speech absolutist that doesn't
mean I approve of all speech hopefully
needless to say you need to say that
there's kind of a couple questions there
in terms of should platforms be able to
you know should you be able to take
someone's video off YouTube or song off
youtube yeah YouTube has a right to do
that private company you know if
someone's putting out some looks just
like you can't put a video out of
someone getting murdered on YouTube and
post it up but you know they're gonna
take that down you can't put a point on
there they're going to take that down so
YouTube already does have content
restrictions and guidelines which is
fair enough like they can do that in
terms of the police and justice system's
getting involved in stuff generally I
think musicians and everybody should
essentially have complete freedom of
speech of course freedom of speech does
not cover genuine calls to violence it
doesn't cause cover like genuine
credible threats towards individuals or
groups and things like that so there is
like a very small tiny percentage of
stuff that's like okay that's that's
going beyond the bounds but outside of
that little tiny segment I would be
hesitant of saying that there should be
any kind of censorship or restrictions
or anything like that because undi with
these things it's always like well who's
who sets the rules right offense is very
subjective as we all know you guys are
comedians so what's offensive to one
person is not offensive to another
person and if you have a big enough
audience you're always gonna have
someone who's offended by something and
you know you know when you don't have a
right no none of us have a right to not
be offended that's not a that's not a
right the freedom of speech Trump's the
freedom sorry that yeah the right to
speech Trump's the right to not be
offended because there is no right to
not be you know you don't want to go
around
living your life and just being being
cruel and offensive to people for
no good reason you're probably gonna get
punched but um I don't think many people
would want to do that anyway I think I
think when people talk about an absolute
right to free speech people always panic
because they're like oh oh they jump to
really like fringe crazy cases yeah and
you're kind of like well no someone
can't call for someone's execution or
harm to be done with someone cuz that
does cross into criminality and I'd say
with music yeah it's just the same rules
should cover it really well let's move
on a little bit cuz as I said you have
been in the news recently and it's it's
an interesting thing so tell everybody
we'll put the clip into this episode so
people can see the video but just
describe it describe what you did and
why you did it yeah okay so on the 26th
of February it's just a normal day I was
actually running at the time for my
music I'm sorry just the words of pop
pop shop so I don't really anyway I
don't think most hipsters even have
pop-ups maybe they shot that maybe they
shoppin I think cookie so I carry
gender-neutral gingerbread person I
posted up a 9 second clip of me doing a
deadlift in the gym yeah just in one of
my training sessions and I weeded it out
with a caption saying I keep hearing
about how there's no biological strength
difference between men and women so
watch me destroy the women's British
women's deadlift record without trying
and that I wrote PS identified as a
woman whilst lifting the weight don't be
a bigot I think the PS is really what
did it you know and it caught fire
within
I want to say within about 20 minutes it
had 10,000 had over 10,000 views within
a couple hours I hadn't broken 100k I
was literally look at my phone and the
retweets and likes were just just
flippin up in real time by the time I
went to bed that same day it had done
over 300,000 views I was seeing it I was
seeing people commenting in all these
different languages so it was going into
all these different spheres of Twitter
I saw it get retweeted by some massive
accounts that had like 500,000 plus 1
million plus followers and it just went
nuts I woke up in the next morning over
half a million views and in total the
videos now the original video is now
what 1.3 million views some of the
interviews I've done have over a million
views I did an interview with party with
two million views on YouTube I did one
with a Ben Shapiro which has got like
350 K and then Tucker Carlson on Fox
News talked about it
Piers Morgan on good morning Britain
talked about it and showed the video it
was covered in Sky News Australia
and then one of the big ones that a lot
of people noticed was on the Joe Rogan
experience on his episode with Bryan
Callen they they had like a five minutes
actually like a five minutes section on
it where they pulled up the video and
they were laughing at it and Joe shouted
me out and followed me on Twitter and
announced it to the audience in
real-time as well so yeah he Rogan now
follows me on Twitter and sent me a
message thanking me for the video and
yeah it's been insane I was featured on
BBC one
BBC Radio One BBC Solent BBC Oxford the
Daily Mail loads loads of places in the
USA so why do you think you've got such
resonance why do you think it got so
much purchase why did so many people
seem to think it was either funny or
relevant or topical or whatever yeah
well I think that I think the timing of
it I think the timing and the execution
lined up far more perfectly than I
imagined when I first tweeted it I mean
I I put out probably 50 tweets a day so
I didn't think that much of it when I
did it I was just like okay my followers
would probably find this quite funny and
I had 19,000 followers at the point I
tweeted it I've now got over 40,000 so
I've gained like across the board I've
gained over 25,000 social media
followers just
in the past month which has been kind of
crazy but um yeah because so the reason
I tweeted initially was because over the
last couple of years I have seen this
rising trend of biological men claiming
to be women or saying they're
transgender and competing against women
in sports it's happened in MMA in
wrestling and athletics and
weightlifting in handball football loads
of different sports and several years
ago I was telling people in private that
this is gonna happen because there's no
reason for it not to alright if someone
is gonna say that this is the women's
league and have an Asterix next to women
and say by women we mean anyone who
identifies as a woman then why would a
man not especially if you're especially
if there's an incentive why would you
not have men or boys starting to compete
in that because they're obviously gonna
have a physical advantage so I'd seen
that happening there had been some
really recent stories last month I think
in some high school in America there was
an athletics race and the people who
came first and second were both
biological men and this is another girls
race there were a lot of questions with
it around the Olympics I didn't realize
quite how big and how global the
conversation was until after this thing
went viral I was kind of like oh wow
this is a bigger debate that more people
are more passionate about than I
initially realized but I think the video
I think won because it it displayed both
the strength and differential because
it's important to keep in mind that
video when I say I wasn't trying I mean
I actually what I wasn't trying that
weight wasn't heavy for me but the point
is I'm not a professional power lifter
there there are plenty there are guys
who can lift several hundred kilos more
than I get Wow okay all right there I'm
not I'm just a I'm a rapper who happens
to go to the gym a lot so I'm stronger
than the average person but um the fact
that someone like me can just stroll in
the gym on any given day and beat all
the women's records and you know that's
um that should show people because I do
genuine they think there are some people
who don't realize quite how big
especially people who don't train people
don't go to the gym
they don't realize just how much
stronger men are compared to women
especially at higher levels is once once
you've had some training in I mean it
can be like double triple quadruple the
strength in some cases and then in like
strengthens and then in speed stuff is
typically about 10 to 12 percent so
there's a reason you separate men's and
women's sports and everyone's always
known that and it's cool all right you
do that so that you can have women
competing and you can have men competing
and that's all that's always been fine
if that's what people ever wanted so I
think because the video demonstrated
that but then also in terms of the
commentary I put on it I think also one
it used the logic of the people who make
those claims people who try to say
there's no difference between men and
women it's all it's all the social
construct it's all sociological all that
kind of stuff which is absurd right
there are but there are people who
actually say that I've heard people
argue that if boys and girls were
socialized in the same way that boys
would not end up stronger than girls are
which is a turn-on play it's I hear
something like that and my brain kind of
doesn't backflip I'm lucky you don't or
you you know I mean like that doesn't
make any sense have you not heard of
testosterone you know so there was that
and then finally I think the fact that
it was funny yeah yeah right it was
satirical so but it but it was a teracle
but not everyone even got that it was
satirical because we live in such a
topsy-turvy world that people often
can't tell the difference between
something being serious and satire so
some of the flack I received was from
people who were angry at me who thought
I was who were you know are angry at me
because they thought I genuinely taken
the woman's record and so they were
saying this is unfair what you're doing
is deeply unfair towards women you know
you're not really not really a woman all
this goes for these long diatribes and I
was like wow and then you know there
were people who thought that I was being
sexist by trying to prove that men were
superior to women there were people who
said I was believed that needs any proof
[Laughter]
killing in Russia
somebody says yeah and then of course
you had a very small percentage of
people trying to claim that it was
somehow transphobic and infer that
because of this deadlift that I somehow
hate trans people or I want them to be I
want some horrible stuff to happen it
you you getting the typical nonsense
people like to throw accusations out
with hope that it'll somehow denigrate
your position because they can't argue
with what you're actually saying but it
was also funny because I responded to a
lot of these things publicly and I was
just claiming that they were being
transphobic right because I'm like
according to your own logic you've said
that I can identify as whatever I want
and also you have this concept of gender
fluidity so I don't even need to that's
why I said I identified as woman whilst
lifting the weights because I've heard
people talk about gender fluidity and
they've said you know for some people
it's day of the week you can depend on
what location they're in what emotional
state they're in so I said well what I'm
in the emotional state of breaking
wanting to break a record I do genuinely
identify as a woman now on the man but
um you know next time I go to the gym I
might I might be a woman as well and
nobody is supposed to deny that
everybody's supposed to accept it so I
kind of kept flip it flipping that back
on all the critics and they just kind of
got frustrated because they were like oh
he knows my arguments too well right so
um yeah the whole thing the whole thing
was really funny it went way further
what way first I ever thought it was
going to but it's been an interesting
couple weeks yeah it's interesting isn't
it because you never know what what
people always assume like with that
story with me earlier in the years well
people always assumed like you made it
go viral right and obviously as
comedians our artists were illegal
maniacs we want every tweet that we put
out to go viral but you never know
what's what's gonna happen and and that
always drives me crazy but you know this
point about hating trans people we had
where India will it be on the show a
couple of weeks back who is a
transgender a woman who is a TV
presenter in this country and we were
talking about this very issue about
women competing against trans women and
sport yeah and she was like well no this
just can't happen if you've gone through
male puberty biology is gonna be
different
but at the same time I have to say you
know listening to her talk about her own
experience and her own story there are
people who hate trans people you know
what I mean and I
think they were trying to lump you in
with those people people trying to do
that with everything don't they yeah
you've got people who think that
literally everyone who voted Briggs it
literally everyone who voted Trump is
racist hmm it's like really you know I
mean like I'm sure there are racist
people who voted Briggs I'm sure there's
people who voted Trump Trump for racist
reasons yeah I'm sure there are people
who voted for is it for racist reasons
but you know I don't know if it's just
how they sound this sounds so elitist
but I just don't know if it's like some
people just don't have the intellectual
capacity to understand there's a
difference between those two things
right just the fact that some that maybe
maybe most racist people did vote for
Donald Trump but that does not therefore
infer that most people who voted for
Donald Trump are racist and I don't know
I don't know if perhaps logically some
people do not even don't comprehend that
just like some people don't understand
that correlation does not equal
causation they'll look at two things
that are correlated and then they
automatically say boom that's that
they'll see any sort of disparity that
exists in any data set and they'll
assume that that must mean there's some
kind of unfair discrimination or
something like that you see this all the
time the most obvious one would be the
whole gender pay gap which has been
debunked literally for about 30 years
all right some people will just take all
the total earnings of men all the total
earnings of women or or sometimes
they'll do it by race I saw Hillary
tweeted about that yesterday and then
they'll just say oh look there's a
difference there for racism there for
sexism and you're just like what like
it's such a I mean you could explain to
a smart seven-year-old why that doesn't
make sense but people just run with it
politicians run with it people just buy
it up people eat it up and I'm it does
my head in because I'm just like how are
you falling for this still it doesn't
take that much thinking to be like oh no
that doesn't make sense if that made
sense you look at them you look at the
NBA and you'd conclude that the NBA is
deeply racist
and white people yeah it's so maybe 70
60 70 percent black unit NFL you look at
these things sprinting hundred meters
200 meters you say wow they're being
discriminatory against non black people
you look at swimming and say man they
must hate black people because there's
no black people in the in the pool and
professional zone and nobody nobody does
this I would understand that these are
absurd arguments but then people do it
with other things they look at a
workplace they look at a university they
look at overall pay they look at all
these things and they'll say ah see this
is evidence of discrimination and to
anyone who's thinking they're just like
no which is why I don't think it's
reaiiy mean the IQ argument I think is
very generous actually because I think
it's probably more sinister than I think
it's so an easy way to undermine people
that you disagree with so you know
arguably what was one of the main
reasons Trump got elected is that people
who were living in the swing state in
America we're losing jobs and that's why
there's a drug epidemic that's why
there's a suicide epidemic but people
don't want to address that it's much
easier to just scream racist yeah you
know and I think a lot of it is intent
and we've seen it you know with the
whole Russia collusion thing which I'm
deeply upset about because I love my
[ __ ] jokes as a russian comedian know
in correction he's lost his job yeah
it's just me talking about so I just
think a lot of it is about in 10 no it's
people who are pushing a particular
narrative and you know a lot of people
know this but you and I went to school
and then we kind of went our separate
ways and pursued our own lives but one
of the first things that may put you
back on on my radar was you put out a
tweet saying a lot of people have the
same opinions as me and privately will
tell me that but they won't say so
publicly and I think you've intimated
what some of those might be but broadly
speaking what do you think it is that we
people are now afraid to talk about well
gosh anything that's important
it's true though isn't there anything
anything in society in morality and
culture and ethics even in science to
some degree that has a risk of being
controversial or contentious right
because again we were talking about
people just making really binary
arguments and trying to see the world in
a really simplistic worldview I mean
that makes some sense from a
psychological perspective because our
brains do all kinds of shortcuts to make
things easier so we the way we see the
world can be just as simple as it needs
to be to navigate it right so it's um
it's much easier to navigate in the
world if you just believe that everyone
who thinks differently right if you're a
liberal and you're looking at
conservatives right it's it's much
easier to understand the world if you
just believe that everyone who disagrees
with you on these policy positions or on
these ideas is evil yeah or it doesn't
or it doesn't or hates poor people or
hates minority or or whatever right and
and that's how a lot of people think or
equally hates capitalism or whatever it
is right or if you're someone who's very
staunchly conservative it can be easy to
just be like oh all those liberals like
they're just they're just stupid or
they're this or they're that right and
so many people do that and they just pit
themselves in these zones people like to
define themselves and then say okay well
of course everybody believes their
worldview is correct right
otherwise you wouldn't have your
worldview if you thought something about
your worldview was wrong if you're you
know a decent person you would try to
revise it and fix it but with so many
people they just root it in it and
that's it you know if someone is if
someone is an atheist again it's very
simple to just go all those people who
believe in religion there's uneducated
and stupid right so I'm a religious
person I'm Christian and I've had people
say stuff on Twitter right who are
atheists and they'll be like oh I'm
surprised someone who went to Oxford can
believe in God and I'm like I don't even
know what to say to that because you're
just kind of like do you are you aware
even that people who founded the science
that you worship were mostly religious
people you see what I mean
and it's like that's that's has nothing
to do with education right it's a belief
system I can I and oftentimes I'll find
maybe just the person I am I'm quite
good at empathizing with other people's
positions so I can completely maybe not
completely but I think I can often
understand other people's worldviews a
lot better than they can understand mine
or other people's but that's largely
just because I try to write I tried
willingness and it's also my ability
it's really this is why we started the
shows because constant needed to be
proved that he was wrong no but but the
reason we started the show is we were
starting to feel like the world doesn't
really make sense to us what you know we
didn't necessarily feel like we
understood why brexit happened okay well
what I knew was that I understood that
it wasn't because this is a racist
country as an immigrant here right so
when that was the main message I was
like well no it's definitely not that so
let's start talking to people who vote
breaks it yeah let's start bringing in
experts who understand both sides and I
think that's what we're lacking in our
culture now is a little bit of humility
to go I don't know everything
let's ask other people and try and find
out what they think and be will and be
willing to be proven wrong and be
willing to find common ground yeah
because the truth is with with any
ideology or worldview or position most
of them have I think some of them are
quite nonsensical but most of them have
some kernel of
objective truth in them right so
oftentimes they'll start with something
that makes sense but then they'll really
they'll greatly extrapolate it to a
stage where it's like whoa okay like the
end result is so far gone that you're
kind of like that doesn't make a lot of
sense but yeah you know there's there's
a lot of humility so for example like
talking about the existence of God for
example right I believe in God but I'm
very I'm humble enough to go I could be
completely wrong
all right maybe there's there's probably
some religious people who won't do that
right but there are atheists they're
atheists for example who I've had
conversations with in in some way I joke
with them that they're more religious
than me
because they'll say I absolutely know
that there is no God and everyone else
who thinks words and I'm like that's
that's a [ __ ] that's a harder line
position than mine
cuz I'm like I believe in God and that's
and I accept that's a matter of faith
III know I can't give you some
scientific mathematical proof of it and
go here see but I can I can explain to
you my my reasoning and my logic and
reason for my beliefs but at the end of
the day I'm like you know what I could
be wrong I could be wrong you know
there's loads of stuff that I believe
that I think and I'm like okay you know
I I could be wrong but what's weird is
when people are presented with data
people people are presented with facts
which disproves them you talked about
this whole Russia collusion thing yeah
right the media how many people have
actually said you know what we were
wrong we blew this we're sorry
no they just said no the report is it's
not right no there was something like it
doesn't matter what that room saw
something it doesn't matter what that
report said we know we know who did it
and it's like you've been you you're
presented with something that goes
against what you believe but people
don't have the humility to just be like
okay fair enough you know like um
because people don't want to change
their minds and that makes sense like I
like being right everybody likes being
right but it there there some there's
things there's big issues that I've
changed my mind on in the last sort of
five years because I've been I've spoken
to other people I've seen other
perspectives and I've had I've had times
where someone's just caught someone's
got a better argument and better facts
and I might okay you're right yeah do
you think it might be even deeper that
and to do with identity for instance
people to identify a certain label yes
so then when they're presented with
something not only challenges the label
they attach themselves you're also
challenging the the the fundamental
structures of how they see the world in
now is unfortunately just too dangerous
and massive a change to go through yeah
it's painful it's painful if you have a
deeply held belief especially if you
hold it for some time and then someone
presents something that counters it or
even challenges it right even if it
doesn't completely supersede it but it
challenges it a lot of people are not
able to deal with that for whatever
reason so sometimes it can be hard for
people to have even have these
conversations because not everybody is
even willing to have the conversation
and I think that's partly because maybe
somewhere deep down they might know that
what they believe is nonsense right they
might know that
the reason you can't challenge it the
reason they don't want anyone to
challenge it is because it can't stand
up to scrutiny so if you believe in some
super weird idea or philosophy or
ideology fantastic example because okay
know you've got people who call
themselves who advocate for communism
you've got people who live in the UK in
the u.s. a capitalistic countries some
of the most wealthy successful equal
best societies in the world by most
measures and they advocate for communism
and you'll be like okay so tell me where
it's worked what about that what about
the Soviet Union what about Vietnam what
about China
what about Cuba right what about
Venezuela right now you'll give them all
these examples and they'll all that
wasn't if I they didn't do it my way or
all that wasn't it wasn't communism that
led to the fall it was it was and this
kind of cognitive dissidence I'm just
kind of I find it very bizarre because
I'm like why would you like most people
can recognize that Nazism was a bad idea
let's not do that again
you know people happily accept that one
but there's like something sexy about
socialism economy communism that people
just want to keep trying it and trying
it and trying it just no matter how many
times it fails and yeah that's quite
fascinating to me
that's because Russia was so the union
was on the Allied side in World War two
true because and that's why the Soviet
crimes were never really exposed yeah no
it's darling killed more people in
Hitler yeah you know but also I think
and it sounds flippant it sounds almost
jokey but I think there is a real truth
to it
Hitler doesn't look good on a t-shirt
shake about our dust might be just brand
branding yeah che guevara that picture
that's an iconic photo
everybody knows who Che Guevara is
without necessarily knowing you store
yeah just cuz he looked so damn sexy and
good on a deer I mean some of it is just
education as well you know I mean some
of that might be because as we as we all
know you know academia is steeped you
know it leans very heavily left both in
school and college and university for
the most part so when people are
learning history I mean how many people
I mean I remember specifically learning
about the Hall
cost and the atrocities of Nazi Germany
in school like I remember seeing the
pictures and watching some videos and it
was steeped in your mind
Nazism bad right it was like it was it
was very clear right no one would it go
but I didn't learn about a lot of the
stuff in the Soviet Union and whatnot
until my 20s and I actively searched it
out and I was kind of confused because I
was like oh how how did this all go on
there's all this stuff all these tens
hundreds of millions of dead bodies and
this was just glossed over completely
and that's that strikes me as quite
pernicious or sinister because I'm like
well no wonder you've got all these
university students running around
waving a hammer and sickle Flags and
thinking that overthrow capitalism this
is one of the things that George all
will actually wrote about because when
he published Animal Farm when he
published 1984 those books were being
suppressed in the UK and that's what one
of the things he was rebelling is he
actually wrote a brilliant essay talking
about self censorship about how
basically at that time he was not
politically correct to criticize the
Soviet Union because they were helping
us helping Britain win the war and then
after there were their allies we didn't
want to poke the Russian bear with all
this [ __ ] and that's why all that stuff
essentially never got properly aired
which is why that ideology isn't as
tainted not
[Music]
but you know talking about stuff that
that is difficult to talk about one of
the kind of main themes I think of of
public discussion certainly in kind of
in the Twittersphere and blogosphere and
then politics now is its privileges
oppression is structural inequality all
this kind of stuff where do you come
down on that
well what about say with the concept of
white privilege for example I think it's
garbage
completely I think it's not garbage I
think someone could argue that there in
any given country you may have some form
of majority privilege I mean the whole
thing of white privilege is it's a it's
essentially a little essay or paper by
some woman that when that went way too
far right you know they had that whole
um I can't remember the name of the
woman who first wrote the paper on it in
the invisible knapsack and whatever it
was in a relatively short paper just
with this idea of white privilege right
it was just kind of an idea and for
whatever reason over the past few
decades people kind of refound this
paper and ran with it and so now you've
got politicians and you've got actors
and you've got just general people
talking about this whole concept so I'm
I don't think it exists and there's
people who criticize me for that I think
I think that's a garbage concept and I
thought and I think it's a harmful
concept it's not just that it's not just
that I am I don't believe it exists I
actually think it's a terrible concept
to try to ingrain in people all these
forms of privilege right if you're
trying to tell males that they have male
perfectly and you're trying to tell
white males they have white white
privilege and male privilege and
heterosexual privilege and this and you
and you're trying to create this whole
well this is Jordan Peterson always
refers the postmodern neo-marxist it's
kind of become a meme I mean by now
right but um but it is true because it's
it's destructive this is the problem I I
don't I don't support any one I think
that yeah like one I don't think it's
true I think that factually like when I
see them when someone talks about why
Pilar's are my okay tell me what exactly
you mean by that
the things they say generally don't have
anything
again oftentimes they can just fall into
majority privilege so they might say
stuff like oh if you buy a plaster it's
the color of it it's closer to a white
person's getting color than then a black
person's it's like okay but if you go to
Africa it's the opposite because that's
the majority or when you're watching TV
you're more likely to see white faces on
TV and then black faces are agent like
you're in England I mean like you're in
England if you go to Nigeria
everything's like every everyone's by
you look at a Nadder you look on TV look
at the films everyone's black it's like
because you're in Nigeria if you go to
China same thing you know it's not it's
not rocket science
I've heard people say stuff like if you
inish in in the shampoo in hotel
bathrooms works better on white people's
hair than it works on afro hair and
again I'm like what country are you in
why why would you expect they're gonna
have some special niche black afro
shampoo in I don't know Cambridge in a
hotel and and then and then similarly
I'm kind of like look even these are the
things people have to complain about
like stuff must be pleated pretty
freakin sorry peep stuff must be pretty
freakin good
yeah if this is what you are complaining
about right if these are your examples
and this is the best you're coming at me
with that I'm like like throw that thing
out the window and then secondly I just
think that it's um I think it's quite a
racist idea to be honest with you I
think it's a very racist idea to start
claiming based on people's skin colour
based on people's sex based on people's
sexuality assuming they have some kind
of advantage or disadvantage that
they've just inherited and that no
matter what they do you know they need
to kind of acknowledge it and atone for
it and check their privilege and you can
now kind of beat them with the stick
right every time you say something I
don't like I can say well you're using
your white male privilege to it to
victimize me well let me use some of my
privilege try and push back on some cake
or the sake of because I hear a lot of
what you're saying yeah but a lot of
people might say well if you and I were
walking down the street in this kind
tray I am not from here you actually
were born here unlike me right but the
police would treat us differently
because I'm white and you're black
according to what well black people are
more likely to be prosecuted black
people are more likely to get a longer
sentence a harsher sentence for the same
crime people say you're more likely to
be arrested
etc right for what arrested for what if
we if arrested for what I mean you more
likely to be stolen essays you're more
likely to be stopped and searched right
we know that okay well I can London or
something yeah yeah okay yeah that's um
there's a couple reasons for that
okay so the whole stop and search thing
that's so that's a good that's a
complicated that's a complicated issue I
mean there are see there everything has
like a flip side so the flip side of
this one is obviously in certain areas
in certain cities in certain countries
the breakdown of demographics who commit
certain crimes is different okay so if
you were looking if you if the police
are trying to sort out knife crime in
London take the obvious example alright
violent crime in London violent crime in
Chicago in the USA take some obvious
examples the vast majority of
perpetrators are young black men vast
majority of victims are young black men
so does that mean that the police this
is where the nuance comes in and people
try to avoid the nuance right does that
mean that the police should then go out
and just target all young black men
because they know that that's the
demographic that commits those crimes at
a higher rate no because the vast
majority of young black men do not
commit any crime so it's a it's a it's a
complex this one's a complex one right
people always try to make it more very
simple because they'll say black people
get arrested at higher rates or are more
likely to be stopped by police and then
it's like okay yeah but that demographic
is also committing more crime so how do
we and people oftentimes people won't
want to acknowledge that fact because
it's not convenient to their argument
but it's like okay you need to put both
these things
on the table and recognize what the
facts are and then you can actually have
a proper discussion of okay well what's
the given these are the stats we might
not like the stats but given these are
the stats how can we now address this
issue trying to say that that in itself
is indicative of white privilege I'm
just kind of like no because you could
say that with you could say that with
any group right men in general commit
far more crime and especially violent
crime than women do so yeah so if so the
rate of arrests between men and women
right significantly more men get
arrested than women do does that mean
that females have female privilege no
you wouldn't say that would be silly for
someone to make that assumption and and
make that conclusion the difference is
between men and women exactly so what so
it wouldn't make sense to make that
conclusion the other way around you
can't just say okay there's a disparity
this is a problem with a lot of the
discourses people just see any disparity
and then they try to just say that it's
this one thing yeah but there are lots
of disparities that exist that don't
have anything to do with racism sexism
etc could they could could no big
factors absolutely right that's probably
there's there's certainly not probably
there's certainly some degree of racism
in society and also in police I think
that's that's been shown that's been
seen to what degree it is would be good
to know but it's hard to even find out
because people are so dug into their
positions that they just want to use the
facts and the statistics and whatever
that are convenient to them well let's
take what you said as the truth which is
that there is some of that happening
right for example are for one of our
former guests I was talking about the
fact that if you do an experiment where
you get a guy with no money trying to
get on a bus and saying to the bus
driver look just let me on I need to go
like three stops would you like a bus
driver is less likely to let them on the
bus without paying if they're white if
they're black they're less likely to do
right so if that exists which I think
you're acknowledging isn't that what
people are talking about when they say
white privilege
I'd actually need to look at that
experiment specifically and see what the
factors were or these people dressed
exactly the same where they equal
attractiveness were they the same height
there's so many factors was it the same
bus driver did you try it with a whole
bunch of different bus drivers and
that's a pretty demand to do that as a
scientifically congruent argument it
would be quite hard to even do the
experiment period so I need to know a
whole bunch of factors right if the
white guy was there dressed in a suit
and looked smart and then the black guys
in a tracksuit
you've already blown up your own
experiment because you know I just last
thing I used to live in London and I can
say that the way people looked at me and
treated me depending on whether I was
going to work in my suit in my tie or I
was coming back from the gym and my
hoodie in my tracksuit I would be
treated differently and people would
look at me very differently I go into
shops and people would respond
differently yeah so that's not based
that's obviously not based on race
because it's literally the same person
it's just how you know people have all
sorts of perceptions about people we
form opinions for better or for worse
quite quickly on people you know
prejudice does exist we all we all
prejudge people all the time as soon as
you see someone in the street you you
form a really quick opinion of it's not
even an opinion but like a pre opinion
almost of what's what's their status
how how how smart might this person be
how attractive is this person how
dangerous could this person be is this
person gonna ask me for something you
know like you do this it's all its
immediate its immediate and so these
things happen and I'm sure again there's
a sex component to that there's a race
component to that even as a guy okay if
you are walking down the street at night
and there's a woman approaching you
versus a man approaching you you will
have a higher you'll have a heightened
level of threat for the man not because
not because you're a sexist towards
towards fellow men but because you know
it doesn't even mean that person is a
threat but yugioh just aware especially
if it's a group what if it's a group of
guys and what if they're big what if
they're what if they're rowdy right what
if they're you know you'll you'll be
like you'll just be on your on your god
especially if you're a woman right a
woman would be more so under guard
whereas if it's a group of three girls
she's probably less likely to
think that thing so yeah it's um it's a
it's a complex all this stuff is really
really complicated but um it's it's it's
stuff that it's good for people to
discuss openly and honestly this is the
this is the problem with over political
correctness when it be when these
subjects become taboo or people don't
want to talk about them openly because
if you do genuinely want to find
solutions if that's what people want
that's what they say they want if it is
what people actually want you have to be
able to discuss these things with nuance
push the emotion to the side and look at
it from a lot of different angles
because most things in the world I mean
human beings are the most complicated
thing that exists you know and it
doesn't also I take it back to identity
again I mean that's a problem with these
types of discussions is when you make a
criticism or even put forward an
argument people feel that you're
criticizing their identity who they are
and then they respond emotionally yeah
and at that point any semblance of
sharing of ideas or listening goes out
the window yeah fortunately I'm not a
very emotional person
I'm really not I'm uh I did a
personality test I'm in the bottom two
percent of neuroticism so I'm like yeah
998 percent of people by default by
definition are far more emotional than
me and susceptible to this stuff but
with me I'm just very I'm very frank
very authentic and I care about I care
about the facts because I do actually
genuinely care also about finding a
potential solution okay I don't like the
fact that you've got violent crime
that's being you know again put it
simply you've got a lot of young black
guys especially who are dying at the
hands of other young black guys whether
it's from guns whether it's from knives
whether it's beating people up whatever
the tool used and it annoys me when
people are pretending to have this
discussion but they're just screaming at
each other and trying to accuse the
other people of you who can you get
these segments on TV it's like who can
be the first to accuse the other of
racism like that's literally the
conversation and I'm like that's not
constructive that's not constructive if
you genuinely want to help these people
if you're Jenny and what don't want to
have grieving mothers and fathers who
have lost their son so you really want
to get
the core of the issue you have to be
able to put on the table and discuss it
openly you want to get a range of people
range of opinions discuss it from
different angles so you don't have too
many blind spots but too many people
target the person who's making people
too many people judge the argument based
on the person who is making it yeah
rather than what the argument is so if
if a white guy if Piers Morgan says
something about knife crime happening
amongst black youth in London right
people will try to demonize Piers Morgan
rather than addressing what he actually
said whether you agree with it or you
have some counter points whether what
people want to just go on and rage on
him and I'm like well you're part of the
problem then because if you genuinely
care about this demographic of people
you generally people in general you you
don't want nobody wants to live in a
society where people are getting checked
so if you genuinely care about that you
have to be willing to accept the facts
and then to try to find a solution and
everybody does want a solution like I'm
not aware of anyone who wants this stuff
to to be going on I'm not aware of
anyone who wants their rate of theft
murder rape to rise you see what I mean
no nobody wants these things so when
people try to claim that that's what
someone wants and you're just it
undermines the entire thing and you just
kind of end up in this useless spin
cycle we've kind of just going around
and everyone's shouting at each other
around the table and it's like okay well
that's not nothing's gonna happen there
and I think part of it as well is
because I do think the root cause of
some of these issues is a lot deeper
it's deep it's deep and it's not easy to
solve right to take a very obvious one I
would say rising rates of single
motherhood rising rates and fatherless
homes big problem yeah we had dr. Tony
so alone sure to talk about that okay
yeah exactly
do you think the reason that this whole
idea and I agree with loads of what you
said that do you think the reason that
this idea of white privilege has become
so viral is that number one it's an easy
explanation of a complex problem and
number two is because there's a lot of
people maybe we're so wealthy now and so
comfortable that we feel guilty about it
and
like this it's white guilt basically
yeah yeah there certainly is there's a
self flagellation element of it surely
because you know I've had why people get
annoyed with me that I don't think white
privilege exists and they're like you
know trying to score woke points with me
by trying to I think a lot of lot of
people assume I believe in a lot of
stuff that I don't right which in its
own way is a little bit racist right
people assume because I'm a black guy
I'm gonna believe that um I'm a victim
or that I'm oppressed and whatever and
I'm like you know I'm like the I'm like
the least on board with that train you
know most people so people will you know
kind of try to say thing frame things in
a certain way and that I will challenge
them on it and they're not expecting it
they're suddenly like I don't know but
yeah I think a lot of it is you know I
guess what you could call virtue
signalling so having someone in a
position or whatever it's better you see
it a lot with like these hot these
Hollywood as an actress it's so crazy
already and they'll be they're like you
know something that reward and
collecting their million dollars and
self-flagellating themselves about how
we need to be more diverse and you know
fight with white male patriarchy and
whatever and then they'll go home and
just do their normal stuff and it's I
think it's got it that way of making
penance and you know try to signal to
the world look I care I care about all
this stuff but it's like yeah that's
whatever um when it's very interesting
how when I talk I've got a friend of
mine who is who's a black comedian and
and whenever I talked to him about
things because his point of view isn't
strictly liberal is not left-wing and
the moment we have a frank and honest
conversation about politics the first
thing it does is turn over look over his
shoulder and then talk to me
oh gosh why is that why is it deemed
that you are not being authentically
black if you are not left-wing why is it
that you can't be black and libertarian
in the UK and somehow you see it's
betraying your race because that's how
they keep people in check and keep their
power you can
have you cannot have this intersectional
left-wing politics without having
oppressors and victims so you have to
pit
white people against people of color I
hate that term by the way you have to
pit men against women you have to have
one you have to pitch it rich against
poor the 1% versus the 99% let's tax the
1% let's text the 1% list half the
people saying that are in the 1% right
so the whole their whole like take the
Democratic Party in the USA if you take
away these narratives then their whole
everything they've been running on for
decades is lost right they've been
running on this is why this is why I've
vehemently disliked the Democratic Party
I don't know don't even want to get
light I'm not really even a partisan but
I really dislike their methods because
you know they just run on telling
forcing black people in America to buy
all these narratives ok so you need us
you must vote for us look at those
Republicans they hate you they want to
keep you down we're gonna look after you
we have white privilege you you you've
been you you're oppressed whatever you
know they'll do the same with women
they'll do the same with gay people any
group that they consider an oppressed
minority to what degree of truth that is
or isn't their entire base their entire
platform their policies and everything
or based on people on mass accepting
these ideas so someone like myself
someone like Kanye West someone like
Thomas soul someone like Clarence Thomas
like those are the people who are gonna
get the most racial I like everyone who
like I've experienced very little racism
in my life the racist attacks and just
the attacks in general I've received
online almost all from liberals like I
don't get attacked by right-wingers it's
always liberal daily it's like this guy
has he's thinking for himself who Kanye
the the whole thing that happened with
Kanye West last year to me it was like
mind-blowing it was mind-blowing I was
like wow like there was some really
the racist attacks on him for simply not
going along with her and I mean in the
state something like 90% of black people
vote Democrat which it doesn't make it
which is freaking weird to begin with
but um yeah it's it's it's just group
think it's group think it's like you
people have been taught this way like I
to me that's like the pernicious actual
racism it's like you've taken this
entire group and as soon as one of them
strays you want you to you need to last
through them and get them back on the
plantation and it's terrible it's
terrible like to me in the modern day in
the modern day I find a lot more oh man
this is gonna sound harsh but I find a
lot more racism on the left wing than on
the right wing and I don't even like to
use those terms because I think that
again stuff is a lot more nuanced than
men people are individuals but I think
that there's like it's like racism with
a cuddle
it's like a different type it's not like
the blade and like you know racial
superiority thing but it's in a way it's
a it's a type of it because it's like
we're so superior that like you need
your you need our help like the
Republicans just want to treat everybody
equally but that's not good enough no no
you you need special you need special
treatment and so what did um is that
soft bigotry of low expectations and it
is because with me I'm just like looked
like I opposed things like a racial
based sex based affirmative action I
opposed it I opposed it across the board
which also surprises a lot of people
because I'm like no I don't give me like
I went to Oxford University I would hate
I would hate it that I went to Oxford
because I was black right there was a
white guy who was smarter than me who
was much better but they only took me
because they needed to hit some number
like that's terrible you don't you don't
want to be doing that you don't want to
be doing that in universities you don't
want to be doing that in companies you
know you don't want to give someone a
role just because they are a woman and
you you just need more women so I'll
give it you know I'm a belief in
meritocracy give it to the give it to
the right person if you want to do
something that encourages certain groups
to apply for more positions or whatever
I'm completely fine with that but if
you're gonna start messing with test
scores or having I mean they're doing
this in the States they've got different
test scores that you need to get into
for certain universities depending on
what race you are
oh man that's far enough they're tryna
compensation privileges kids majority
there are eighty percent Asian just
destroying it mean you start
discriminating that's insane to me
but that feeds so much into the point
that you made earlier which is what
you're allowed to say depends on your
skin color like if we switch seats and
or it may be better so in a way we are
what you joke but in the way we are in
the position where certain people are
allowed to say certain things and other
people are not it's intentional and
people will assume that you have certain
positions because you're black and that
is racist yeah yeah but you know like I
said I'm good at people using people's
own logic in games against yeah so if
that's how they want to roll then um you
know I will use my black privilege in
that case and I will look I'm always
gonna be authentic that's my thing
that's really my one of my North Stars
and life just being keeping it real
really real telling the truth being
authentic I try not to ever lie I try
not to disguise or mask what I think for
the sake of being PC or for somebody who
I don't know liking me I don't care you
know the people who keep the people who
love me love me so I'm not I'm not
really worried about those other things
if someone wants to challenge any of my
positions or maybe thinks I have a blind
spot or anything like that cool like I'd
love to talk to someone who really
believes in all these narratives right
and they explained to me in their
position I'd love to have that
conversation but with a lot of those
people they're the type who just want to
stick their fingers in their ear and
scream and call you names and stuff like
that you know if someone like that is
sensible then I'm like cool you know if
someone talks about take take some of
these issues institutional racism
institutional sexism systemic wear you
know these things people talk about I'm
like okay if you can I'd like to dig
into them right if someone just says
okay if you if there's something
specific because I'm not even I'm not
saying that there's no there might be
some policy or some thing or some
institution or some school or justice
systems there might be something that
does genuinely have that issue but we
need to laser in on it to do anything
about it there's no point just going on
the street and holding up a sign saying
I oppose institutional racism and
marching around and shouting it's like
what does that even mean do you even do
the person holding that sign even know
know what it means and it's like you'll
drill down and you find they don't write
but it's like if you can find a
particular policy a particular rule a
particular institution whatever that is
exhibiting racist behavior I'm like cool
like let's zero in on that and people on
every side of the spectrum will want to
solve that because this idea that
conservatives or a whole bunch of people
want people to be oppressed or want
people to be held down they want they
want to keep women out of this they want
to keep minorities things
it's nonsense we're not living in 1950
thank God
Yeah right you know there was a time
when that was the case and there was a
much better case for a lot of these
ideas because it was real alright if we
were in 1950 and someone said is the
white brother Jay I'll be like yeah well
look we can't do that I can't do that I
can't do that I can't get this job I
can't do that because of my skin color
yeah and these concepts may exist in
certain country you know whatnot may
they do exist in certain countries still
I grew up in Saudi Arabia if someone was
like is there why is there male
priviledge women can't drive so of
course there is kind of a yeah i think i
think it's still like actually would be
quite dangerous considering you're just
starting now yeah can i just say to the
producer can we just get well you know i
always say people are people that make
assumptions about me they're like they
think that because I'm Russian I don't
respect women irony guys welcome to
[Music]
no man listen it's been a great
absolutely great interview talking about
blind spots so the last question we
always ask is what is our blind spot as
a society what do you think is the one
thing that no one's talking about that
we walk oh boy oh boy there's gonna be
really heavy
what heavier than what I just done mm-hm
yeah okay go yeah yeah abortion okay
yeah I think that needs a more serious
discussion I think it's the biggest
blight on society and I think a real
serious discussion and elevation of
consciousness is needed around it so to
make that more specific for us I'm
guessing given that you're religious
you're probably against abortion yeah
not from a religious basis but okay I'm
against it yeah yeah I mean you got
those our human lives and thousands are
being taken every day and it's very much
out of sight out of mind and it's
certainly not a dinner table parte
conversations hopeful that anyone wants
to get into but um the way I look at it
is very similar to how I imagine the
people who wanted to abolish slavery
would have felt like hundreds of years
ago and you've you've got this thing
that everybody accepts and it's been
going on for a thousands of years and
people aren't questioning it and it's
deemed as a you know slavery was always
deemed from the perspective of the
slaveholders rights right we have a
right to do this we have a right to use
abortion generally in the Western world
is very much framed as from pro-choice
people of course as a woman's rights
issue right and very little very few
people ever think about the baby fetus
if you want to if you want to you know
use the use the euphemism and it's all
it's all it's completely framed in that
regard not from pro-life people pro-life
people are like um what about the baby
that's being killed right but um I think
that they're I think that that whole
conversation of societies yet mature
enough to have that conversation but
it's a conversation that I do think is
is needed like it's something that
troubled me it's something that troubles
me everyday genuinely it troubles me it
troubles me a lot not because it
directly impacts
but just knowing the rates of it you
know looking at the numbers I mean in
some parts of the US I mean black babies
in particular have a 50/50 chance of
being aborted okay so over fifty million
potential Americans have been killed
since in the past like 40 years or
something like that I don't know the
exact figures in the UK but um
considering how far we've come in a
society in terms of just like
consciousness and treating people
decently and humanely and stuff like
that that one does trouble me to know
that the most vulnerable members of the
human species are not even considered in
those things and I know it's it's a very
polarizing topic it's something people
get very heated on understandably on
both sides but um yeah in terms of a
societal blind spot or something people
just don't want to don't want to touch
don't want to talk about I do think that
it's to me personally it's a it's
something seriously yeah I think the
thing with that is that I is such a
difficult issue because I don't think
it's about maturity I'm not sure that
issue is ever gonna get resolved we're
never gonna find like a solution because
it's kind of halfway and there's always
gonna have to be a compromise and when
you're talking about human lives
compromises don't really make the
problem this is the problem that's the
thing so I guess I feel like the place
we're at now is it's in this country
it's kind of as good a compromise as
you're probably gonna get then again you
know the human lives and these are these
are people and so we're talking not
everybody even accepts that not only
because they're bullshitting themselves
they don't want to have the real they
don't want to go we're killing people
but maybe we we should be allowed to
sometimes you know like that's really
the compromise we're at yeah because
it's kind of halfway it is a woman's
rights issue it is a woman's right to
show on the one hand another hand it is
killing people and you have to be able
to hold both of those in your head yeah
and be okay with that and that's very
difficult to do yeah and most people
don't even accept what you just said
Yeah right most people who are
pro-choice would either try to say that
that's not a human life
or they just yeah but well there's
millions of people who hold that
position you know I think they just
trying to defend their argument yeah no
I think so too
I think so too because at least that's
an honest position if someone again you
have to at least put the facts on the
table yeah you know put the facts on the
table again you know and my argument is
not from a religious standpoint at all
it's not religious at all it's just
saying you know do you believe that it's
wrong to kill innocent human beings yeah
99% of people will say yes yeah okay
most people will accept that stabbing a
newborn baby is wrong and you should go
to prison for it okay but a lot of
people think that until that baby comes
out you can chop it up yeah right so you
can stab it as long as it's still in the
womb you can stab it and I'm like how
does that make sense yeah the given
given you just said like everybody is
very grateful three minutes that's the
half the problem right notion that men
shouldn't have our babies made yeah what
about the father
each of these babies has a father Yeah
right so and also the father's gonna be
on the hook for the father's good no no
the men made his decision when he when
he ejaculated okay but didn't how come
the women's decision wasn't also made
then right you've still got they've got
the urge to carry the baby of course
it's complicated it's very complicated
but yeah I think it's a conversation
that should be I know why it's not more
out in the open but it's something that
I think that um again it's very out of
sight out of mind yeah but I think it's
something that people should so you
would want to believe wouldn't want to
eliminate it completely you would want
no abortions to happen I would love no
abortions to happen ever
yeah is that a realistic position that
we're gonna reach tomorrow no it's not
yeah but just like I don't want children
to be I don't want infanticide ever tap
and I don't want murder every time I
don't want rape ever to happen but those
things are all illegal so would you want
to make it completely illegal that's a
good question well before before even
getting there there's no point in even
having that discussion until
the discussion that wider discussion is
being had because it affects a lot of
things you know it comes down to
relationships it comes down to people's
sexual behavior it comes down to a whole
bunch of things and this goes for both
men and women right a lot of people
think this is trying to like pin
everything on women or whatever and it's
like no no I'm talking just as much to
guys you know if you're gonna run around
there and be sleeping could be sleeping
with all these women and you know kind
of like jetting off and whatever it's
like again that's why I was saying I
don't know if society's ready to kind of
have that bigger conversation of like
okay what are the what's what's right
and what's wrong
yeah you know we've got it a lot of the
other things what I find weird is you
know you've got this rise in veganism
animal rights ideas all these kinds of
things and with me again sometimes I'm
like okay so you're saying it's deeply
wrong to kill a chicken or a fish to eat
but a human being as long as it's not
born yet it's okay to it's epically fine
to the Venn diagram for vegans and
pro-abortion people is gonna be pretty
yeah this is the thing that's why it
confuses me because it's like
consciousness is rising in all these
other areas you see what I mean yeah and
that's good yeah that's cool so I'm kind
of like well how about that one and I
think a lot of it is people have not one
it's something people lie about a lot
because the people who are pro-choice
don't like to put the facts out there
the facts aren't actually very that very
fact are uncomfortable and they will
shift people's in the other direction
this what happened with me I used to be
kind of like it just wasn't something I
thought about yeah it wasn't something I
thought about and then someone you know
presented an argument to me and we were
just you know we were talking about it
properly and I was like yeah it's really
wrong isn't it you know I mean like yeah
like you know like I I had to give up my
position because I was like yeah you're
right you know I was like yeah you're
right it just wasn't something I'd
really thought about before I just kind
of had like a default position like you
know whatever but not like I really
thought about I guess at and I thought
about it and I was like yeah that's
that's a human life that makes sense you
know I've got nine nieces and nephews
in a way that cambrian I mean I was born
like if I rewind in my own life it's
like okay where would it started didn't
just magically start when I came out and
took my first breath it's like I was
obviously still me yeah when I was in my
mother's stomach right so I was like
yeah okay you win you know and from that
on literally I turned pro life in like
20 seconds and yeah so I think it's a
it's a conversation that needs to be it
needs to be had some people will hate me
for that I've had hundreds of people
unfollowed me on Twitter after finding
out I'm pro-life but I'm gonna speak my
truth and if people don't like it or
they want to shy away from opinions that
may differ from theirs then that's on
them I'm happy to talk to anybody you
know what I mean I don't know sorry to
pull it down so all the positivity yeah
except when it comes to women who ladies
are two three female followers we love
you we respect you that's just me trying
to be charming just listen guys whatever
gender you I if you've enjoyed us
talking to zoobi he is a brilliant
musician very interesting guys you've
seen make sure you follow him on Twitter
on Instagram on all the social media
YouTube channel as well the zoo be
podcast tell us about that quickly
before yeah sure thing um so I I do
podcast twice a week called Real Talk
with zoo be that um conversations with
interesting guests very open dialogue
very much Pro free speech you can also
find me on Twitter at zoo be music same
Facebook and Instagram at Subic as any
be Y music my website is ubi music calm
and my new album perseverance is out
right now it's great stuff yeah check it
out and as always follow us on all the
social media at trigger pod make sure
you subscribe to the YouTube channel
zoobi has one as I'll subscribe to his
but on our YouTube channel make sure you
click that Bell button next to the
subscribe button to make sure you get
all the videos leave us an iTunes review
if you're a listener this podcast if you
don't know is also available in audio
form only on iTunes and all other
podcast platforms and we will see you a
again in a week from now with another
brilliant episode absolutely and if you
please check to see if you've been
unsubscribed if you have recent scribe
tell us and continue to spread the hate
all right see you next week guys
[Music]